[Applaudissements]
une marie de manifestants ont pris
d'assaut les rues de washington
ils ont animé une capitale qui tourne
plutôt au ralenti ces derniers jours en
raison de la paralysie du gouvernement
nous sommes ici parce que nous croyons
que donald trump ne devrait pas être à
la maison blanche qu'il doit être
destitué affirme une manifestante
arborant un bonnet rose l'emblème de ce
mouvement un mouvement qui est né le 21
janvier 2017
au lendemain de l'investiture de donald
chambre les centaines de milliers de
femmes avaient convergé vers washington
pour répudier leur nouveau président en
elles ont marché aux états unis ni
ailleurs dans le monde pour dénoncer le
harcèlement et les violences contre les
femmes dans la foulée durement moi aussi
cette année les manifestations
organisées dans de nombreux pays dont
l'angleterre et canada avait pour thème
de mettre fin à la violence contre les
femmes
[Musique]
selon les organisateurs ces marges
commence à peine à éveiller les
consciences
on va voir les progrès le progrès plus
tard dans deux trois quatre langues
parce que maintenant les gens doit
accepter et doit savoir l'information à
montréal les manifestants qui n'avaient
pas froid aux yeux ont défendu les
femmes les plus marginalisés notamment
celles issues des premières nations
les fleurs rouges c'est vraiment pour
les femmes autochtones au canada qui
sont selon moi pas assez protégé par le
corps policier et le gouvernement et
certains pays où on est assez privilégié
pour se sentir égal pour sentir qu'on a
atteint ce niveau où on en a plus besoin
mais je pense que à tous les jours aux
nouvelles dont on entend parler de ce
qui se passe
pire on se rend compte qu'il ya encore
d'autres marches ont eu lieu ailleurs au
pays notamment à vancouver toronto
ottawa et fredericton ici nancy caouette
radio-canada à montréal